[Musique]
quant à vous je vous félicite
je vous félicite d'abord d'être jeune il
n'est que de voir cette flamme dans vos
yeux pour savoir que devant votre élan
la vie n'a qu'à bien se tenir et que
l'avenir est à vous ayez l'ambition que
le progrès sur le bien commun que chacun
en ait sa part qu'il permet d'accroître
le beau le juste et le bon partout et
notamment dans les pays qui comme les
nôtres fond la civilisation qui procure
au milliard d'habitants des régions
sous-développées de quoi vaincre à leur
tour la faim la misère l'ignorance et
accéder à une plaine goûter clip des
jeunes français faire en sorte que tous
les lieux de chez vous de chez nous se
rapproche toujours davantage se
connaissent mieux celui plus étroitement
[Musique]